happiness or fulfillment does not depend
on any other humans acceptance of who
you are that would be a deluded thought
if you think you can only be happy if
these people accept and understand you
some people have that with their parents
so they say my dad don't understand me
at all it's terrible terrible I'm trying
to explain they cannot understand you
it's beyond their comprehension if you
have awakened spiritually and they
haven't except that they cannot
understand you instead of trying to
explain yourself to them just be there
in a loving way with them when you meet
for Christmas or Thanksgiving and you
hear all the judgments coming at you
from them so you don't not need to
justify you accepting people's
limitations and suddenly realizing
whether or not your father your mother
your sister your brother or anybody else
Close to You accepts you for who you are
you become free of the need to be
accepted but you can nevertheless have a
deeper connection keep that deeper
connection and connectedness with them
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because the
thing that saved me as an entrepreneur
was watching the stories of other
successful entrepreneurs and I learned
from their advice I learned from their
motivation and honestly I have no idea
where I would be if I didn't have those
videos to inspire me I still need them
for myself today too and I hope that
they can inspire you as well so today
let's learn from one of the best Eckhart
Tolle and my take on his top 10 rules of
success enjoy
rule number two is develop rational
thinking I've had this strange feeling
idea in the past few months
that a certain segment of humanity is
uh
losing the ability to think rationally
there's a decrease in whether I call it
IQ or whatever it may be
there is a diminishment of rational
faculty
as reflected in many ways on
mainstream media social media and so on
and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware more aware
more conscious is not drawn into
the regressive
phase that some of humanity may be going
through It's Not Unusual for Humanity to
occasionally collectively regress to a
lower State of Consciousness it has
happened
whenever a country or Collective has
been taken over by uh and almost one
could say toxic ideology that has
completely taken possession of millions
of people's minds
look at of course national socialism in
Germany the maoist cultural revolution
was quite crazy what happened in
Cambodia under polypod uh totally crazy
ideas
invaded millions of people's minds and
the
reduce their ability to to actually
engage in rational thinking and
it thinks it happen for example in Mao
East China during the cultural
revolution
um
children reporting on their parents when
they were angry with their parents all
they had to do is go to school and
Report their parents if they had said
something against the
government the pounds would be taken
away and never seen again they they went
around public parks in big cities in
China tearing out flowers out of because
beauty is regardless Bourgeois you have
to kill your back your pets your your
dogs and cats
totally in these are just a few examples
of totally toxic and irrational thoughts
taking over people's minds so that's to
some extent I've been seeing this
happening uh collectively not just in
one country in quite a few Western many
Western countries that I'm aware of and
but it has not affected everybody
some people have managed to remain aware
they have not been one could say
infected by what one could perhaps call
a a mental virus or mental viruses that
reduce people's ability to actually see
reality reality then gets distorted
through the veil of these mental viruses
that have taken over people's minds
this is
um
uh more serious more serious pandemic
than anything that happens on the
physical level as far as
pandemics are concerned the actual
viruses
actually you might I don't know if
you've read Carl Jung said that the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
not from any external Force like natural
disasters or
diseases or pandemics that he said the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
uh
Collective psychosis rule number three
is be a good listener for someone who's
a little bit hyperactive
what's the best way to get a balance
between
removing content which is really good
but then not getting annoyed when
content comes in and you think oh it's
it's spoiling
my piece is there somewhere to get a
balance be more a listener than a
speaker make that your practice for the
time being
just I'm not saying don't say a word
but be more like 80 percent a listener
than a speaker and that would for
example you can do by
asking questions when you're in a rather
than stating your view or whatever it is
ask questions that encourages the other
person to speak more
if the other person speaks more it
forces you to listen and then make the
listening into a practice while the
other person is speaking
are you able to let's at any time to
feel your inner body can you feel that
the hands then I seem to lose them quite
quickly okay but but hence you can't
feel the energy in your hands the rest
of the body is more difficult yeah yeah
okay well it's a good start it's a start
so I suggest that once you've asked a
question while you listen
you direct your awareness into the inner
feeling of your hands
and that keeps it there so that it
doesn't your mind doesn't take off
so
you ask a question what
um where you're from how long have you
been with
a card how did you first discover the
the books
have you been to other many questions
you can ask and people will be happy to
help you by answering your questions and
they will be happy to help you by not
asking you too many questions
listen
have your attention in the inner energy
field of your hands if if you can
amplify that and have your attention
also in other parts of your body for
example your feet and hand at the same
time that's even better but hands is
fine too so you feel your inner the
aliveness in your hands and from there
you you listen and you know
he just giving this will help you
prevent the stream of Mind from taking
you over rule number four is live in the
moment how do I strike a healthy balance
between simply accepting life as it
unfolds and actively working towards and
striving towards goals destinations
aspirations well accepting life as it
unfolds of course is the foundation for
conscious and sane living accepting
whatever
unfolds in the present moment there is
nothing else
that's the foundation doesn't mean you
cannot
have
goals
you cannot have aspirations wanting to
achieve this do this do that it's
perfectly compatible with accepting what
is arriving in this moment
one difference between the unconscious
state which denies this moment and wants
to make it into a means to an end all
the time
the difference then is
what is the motivation for your doing
If you deny this moment
can never embrace it honor it and
appreciate it
then the motivation for your action is
basically dissatisfaction with what is
and the action is looked towards as a
possible way of overcoming the
discontent and the dissatisfaction that
you feel with the present moment
and that's a very normal pattern and
that's in for many many people that what
is what motivates them they don't feel
good enough they don't feel
there's something they feel there's
something fundamental missing in their
lives they don't feel recognized they
don't feel loved
whatever and so they try to find
something achieve something that will
bring them that which they feel is
missing
they don't realize that
that is not going to work you need to
start with
the foundation for your life which is
this moment
and go deeply into that
and become
okay with it friendly with it realize
it's the only thing there ever is just
this moment nothing ever exists that's
not this moment
so you might as well
become friendly with it and appreciate
it
and look around and see how actually
it's okay this moment is actually okay
and if it's not okay that you can still
say well that's what it is right now
something goes wrong that's what is
and then things will come in that you
want to do you suddenly an idea comes or
you need to do something to make a
living
and then out of that state of becoming
one with the isness of the present
moment
something Rises and wants it wants to
take form in the world that perhaps you
want to create and then you created out
of the joy of doing instead of out of a
feeling of lack that you need something
to make you complete or happy
so the motivation changes from
neediness and discontent
to
[Music]
joyful doing
it's not stressed anymore
when stress is a sign that you've lost
the present moment
the next moment has become more
important than life itself also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is practice
manifestation the greatest obstacle is
probably
when meditation comes out of a sense of
lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of some thing be it money
or
a relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
I want a better job I want a job with a
good income and a life situation in a
nice place and I want this and I want
that
by making these statements
you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so you're also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want there is the statement
I don't have
and I need
similar things please give me if you you
pray to so maybe God maybe you pray to
Jesus maybe you pray to Buddha they do
that in Buddhist countries maybe you
pray to a saint or whatever it is or you
pray to the universe and say please
universe please give me this please give
me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works it could be accidentally who knows
but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because instead
the manifestation practice arises out of
a state of lack or neediness so there's
no powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestationist was one simple sentence
it says when you pray for something
believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
is believed that you have received it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it rule number six is learn to say no my
North Star is the monk the story you
shared about the monk who lived saying
is that so for everything that came I am
trying
my best to get there in my journey to
accepting the easiness of things and
accepting the moment what I'm struggling
with is
when am I being a doormat how do I
determine it's clear in the example you
just shared being homeless
in the gray areas of life how do I
determine when I need to take action the
important thing is
non-resistance is not so much to do what
externally what you do but it's a it's
an inner state of consciousness of
non-resistance acceptance of what is of
the present moment in this this moment
um
it doesn't if it's misunderstood then it
could lead as you say it could lead you
to become a doormat because then you
would go along with with what everybody
say anybody says to you uh
and you would can you do this can you do
this for me yeah okay I can do it
and then you could be used by people
uh
but a state of non of non-resistance
sometimes
um
may require you to say no
to uh or did they say somebody requests
something but you feel you don't want to
do it or you cannot do it
for some reason
and you say no
I I don't I think I wrote about this
that I I had this expression
a high quality no
as opposed to a low quality no a low
quality noise you make the other person
into
a kind of enemies and
why you always ask me this doctor
you used to argue on yourself you accuse
the other bird you're just trying to use
me I can see it you've used me before
and now you're doing it again now you're
asking me for money again I've already
lent you five times here have you given
it back to me no you haven't so no I'm
not going to do it just don't leave me
alone
let's Wanna Know
and then there's another note which is
non-reactive it's not all right does not
arise from reactivity but is a response
to the situation that this uh no I don't
want to let's say whatever the request
is or the demand no I I can't do it
anymore I don't want to do it anymore no
I'm not going to give you money again
because I've already given you five
times so I just um I won't give you
again uh that's just how it is I know I
can't uh no no I cannot
[Music]
oh
whatever it may be you're saying no
without creating an anime without
reading or a situation without making a
situation into an enemy
so it's a conscious no and you're still
in an inner state of non-resistance
the state of resistance strengthens the
ego and this is a way of not operating
through not operating through ego rule
number seven is declutter your mind I
wonder could to connect that to what I'm
doing with this month
um I I suppose someone like you kind of
kind of digs something like this the
idea that someone could put down the
devices and I wonder what what do you
think just in general about a world that
is so obsessively connected to other
people's thoughts all day long yes
that's good so um the over this um
excessive identification with thinking
and overthinking excessive thinking have
been there for a long time long before
we came up with these devices
but these devices
amplify the human tendency to to engage
or indulge in excessive thinking and
problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking focused thinking
uh so the what you are doing
is very very helpful because you are
basically
[Music]
having a period of what we could call it
decluttering your mind you declutter
your mind and this is necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
be again as cluttered as they are now
Gladden means there's a continuous input
of
stuff that comes in through the devices
the messages come in Facebook posts
tweets and continuously the devices
demand your attention and say this is
important and a lot of it is not
important
but as we all know
there's an addictive quality to it it
draws your attention to it and then
every time it draws your attention you
add to the Clutter of your mind a lot of
not is not constructive
a lot of it is just random people often
see people they get out their phones
and they do this random scrolling I can
see it's random there's nothing specific
but they think they have to do it
because everybody else is doing it
around them wherever you are these days
people are engaging with this and
they're continuously taking in
thoughts from others and as we said
before
some of these thoughts may be toxic and
they may easily become lost in your mind
so to declutter is extremely important
and you can see if you even just not
using a device for a day for many people
is very very hard
uh and some think they can do it but
they can't so they are truly addicted
um now when you when you when you
declutter your mind
first of all you put down your phone you
don't use it not everybody can do it for
whole months like you of course but I
recommend to everybody to have certain
periods of time when they do not engage
so for example in your bedroom might be
a good place to start for not engaging
with any device uh certain periods of
time when you go out into nature
be there rather than carry that thing
and every time it makes a noise you
still look up and you still eat money
surrounded by Beauty and aliveness
you're still engaging with this rule
number eight is manage your addictions
and the moment you watch the screen
whether it's television or whatever
screen you might have noticed that
the your own your so-called own thought
processes come to a stop so to some
extent you're free of the self this is
why people sometimes find watching
television relaxing say okay I just need
to relax now let's turn it on
by this they mean while they watch the
television screen they are not burdened
by their
self-induced thought processes what they
do however they replace
the their own Thoughts with the for
Collective thoughts so they just the
United States you're not in a state of
thoughtless awareness when you watch
television or you watch something on the
screen you absorb the swords from there
into your mind and you you link in so it
for people often in a state of semi or
hypnosis when they was and it kind of
paralyzes you it can also happen with
the screen with television already
started of course
um I don't know when whenever 60 years
ago whenever television started and you
go
and so your mind is just absorbing
whatever is playing it's the TV Minds
which is receiving stuff from where it
comes from it's going into your mind and
you become a
no longer thinking your own thoughts
occasionally your mind you say oh this
guy is so stupid and then you're
watching again
and then another thought why am I
watching this rubbish
half an hour later
this is so awful
but you can't you can't you can't turn
it off
here's the here's the remote
let's let's just try one more Channel
there might be something else there
oh no that's stupid try one more
this is this is how an addict behaves
and the device is even more addictive
you'll go because you carry them with
you
and
you have to admit you may have to admit
that
you there's an addiction in you that not
everybody here but quite a few it would
be almost normal to feel this draw
towards it and you use it even when you
don't need to use it that's the amazing
thing
when you're standing at the elevator
waiting
it's another person standing next to you
and he or she is pulling out the phone
and then you pull out yours if you don't
know why
anywhere you are in a you are waiting
you're ordering a tea or coffee
somewhere and you're standing in line
and if you look around there's almost
nobody and probably nobody who is not
looking at this little thing
this is scary
zombie-like well number nine is
acknowledge your emotions the feeling
first of all needs to be acknowledged
and accepted
you can't start with letting go so you
have to start with acknowledging it
and accepting that it's there because
it's part of what is the is-ness of the
present moment whether it's an external
thing or an inner thing it is it is what
is
uh and to deny or to argue with what is
creates suffering
so
you acknowledge you accept that it's
there
then
how much time you need
to be with it
depends varies from person to person and
what what kind of feeling it is and so
on
and then the question arises what is the
link between that feeling and your
thought processes
the
person needs to
find out
whether the thought process is
keep that feeling alive continuously
whether they renew by playing out for
example a past scenario in their minds
by Reviving memories from the past
by dwelling on certain narratives that
are painful
repeating them in their minds
that gives Renewed Energy to the feeling
so the first the most important thing is
to be aware of both levels
what's the level of my thinking how does
that contribute to the perpetuation of
what I feel
and so you also then acknowledge that oh
this these are the Habit your thought
patterns that go through my mind in
relation to the feelings
and then the you would begin to realize
that
the Letting Go the most important step
in letting go of feelings is to cut the
link between
your thinking and what you're feeling
how do you do that
you do it by
by being aware of your thinking and
realizing
that that thinking is pain
it feeds the old feeling and the
narrative whatever it is is a painful
narrative
and you realize that you've been keeping
it alive for some years
and you when you there's some enough
awareness you realized that it has no
purpose
except to make you unhappy and to
perpetuate that feeling angry number 10
the last time before some very special
bonus Clips is connect with nature oh
yeah there may be one or two people
being with us here
there
who perhaps are stuck somewhere in a
room and can't get out because of
physical disability or they may be in
prison
and they say what can I do what can we
do we can't get out into nature
well you need to remember that your body
also is nature so you can start there
every time you take a breath
that's nature nature is breathing the
air that you're breathing is nature
the very fact of breathing is a natural
process
it's not choice
it's done for you it's not so much that
you praise although we say I breathe
but you're not the body breathe is so
it's a natural thing that happens you
wouldn't say I'm beating my heart you
don't do that but that's the same thing
the body does it it's a natural process
for some reason we say I'm breathing
because breathing is semi-voluntary
you can't stop it for a while
but not for that long because if you
stop it for too long nature takes over
and they go
so nature takes as nature you live with
nature with your body
so even if you can't get out you can
start by being aware of that level of
yourself
the the physical level
the natural part of Who You Are
the body and not just by saying okay
I'm looking at my hands or my feet not
just the physic not the external image
of the body
but you can go into the body with your
attention
and that's your nature even if you're in
a prison cell you can do that
and even if there's no opportunity you
might be in an office Block in Manhattan
and you look out of the window and all
you have is maybe a little bit of sky
okay there's a little bit of nature
there you can look at that
but you have more nature than that in
yourself so as you sat in your office
wherever it is
go within first be conscious that
breathing is happening
the body is breathing
be conscious also of the the
preciousness of the air
it's such a precious substance
so to acknowledge that
is actually part of what sometimes is
called to live in a state of
gratitude
now some people say what can I be
grateful for there's nothing in my life
that I can be grateful for well are you
breathing
yes well you start there
you can look at the world wars you can
look at all the terrorism and all the
other mad Wars that are being fought
as just
it's just a question of degrees of
unconsciousness not different
so when you go into that state of
unconsciousness you it takes you over
you lose it
basically then that is the same energy
field
that has created
what we see as the Mad Madness of human
history
and what we see of The Madness of the
so-called world news
the same energy so don't complain about
all these violent people who are doing
all these Dreadful things all that it is
is human or unconsciousness in a more
pronounced form than yours
or your partners
and so
that helps a little bit to find perhaps
it's almost some compassion
towards
all these crazy people
that are doing such crazy things and
creating such terrible suffering now if
you become compassionate towards them
don't worry
it doesn't mean that they will not
experience
the consequences of their
unconsciousness that still happens you
by being compassionate to another human
being you don't necessarily remove the
karmic consequences of their action
but
you yourself
become free from the from being drawn
into the karmic cycle
so the
the act of forgiveness
does not mean
that this person is not going to suffer
the consequences because life makes sure
in whatever form that they do suffer the
consequences of the suffering that they
inflict on other human beings it's a
karmic law
but if you don't want to be part of that
anymore if you want to
step out of the karmic law the the first
step out of the and the most important
step out of the karmic law is
forgiveness
then you do not feed it you don't become
part of it that's why traditionally in
spiritual teachings of various
traditions
forgiveness is always emphasized it must
be real though it's there are many forms
of superficial forgiveness when Justin
minus okay I forgive you it's not deep
it's not real yet
the mind is trying to forgive but you
you can only forgive
if you realize that whatever actions
have been perpetrated are the effects of
human unconsciousness
in other words what Jesus said on the
cross or is reported to have said
forgive them for they know not what they
do
very profound statement it is a profound
statement that can be applied to any Act
of
violence perpetrated against other
humans or life forms forgive them for
they know not what they do
not knowing what they do of course means
they are unconscious
the word unconscious probably in that
sense wasn't used at the time
so he said they don't know what they do
karmic law still operates
but without you
and you can notice karmic law
[Music]
answers
when when you see a movie some movies
like to manipulate your emotions
and so there are particular types of
movies where they first they build up
the tension by showing you some very
evil persons
and this evil person is killing all
these people or hurting all these people
and then you're being manipulated
to feel that incredible pull that this
person should suffer for what he or she
has done that's the manipulation the
audience loves it they love watching
things like that
so then the emotion builds up and
finally there even some movies like The
the movies that uh about um
Vigilantes who take justice in their own
hands because the justice system doesn't
deal with the criminals anymore so
finally you have this guy who goes out
and kills all the bad guys and the your
emotions have been manipulated so much
that the audience that yes yes he must
die not realize no what you what you are
free what what you are feeling this
incredible it might also happen if you
read about some Dreadful crime that
somebody has committed and then if you
read it on the internet the you can read
in some on some news websites you can
read the comment section
and in the comment section on every
other comment says we should have the
death penalty who needs to say electric
chair he needs to be
done to what he did did he they should
do to him and all these and this is an
enormous pressure that people feel
inside and this is connected to karmic
law because there's a competence
compensatory factor in karmic law and
you can feel that as the pressure inside
you but it keeps you trapped in karma
huh so in that sense watching these
movies is not helpful
because it keeps you trapped in that
that wheel of the of karma so they don't
teach forgiveness there so
this is we are talking it's about
something very important and that is
dealing with human unconsciousness and
what looks like evil
they saw there are many things that uh
quite Dreadful so how do we how does
that affect our state of consciousness
and what role does our state of
consciousness play in this whole
scenario it does have a role to play
so it's
for us
important
that we are no longer part of
action and reaction because the
definition of karma is action comma
means action and reaction and it goes on
and on and as you can see in certain
societies and so on the karmic thing
goes on what goes back centuries and
centuries the same grievance
transmitted from one generation to the
next and the next and the next and they
are all asleep
this is why spiritual teaching say that
you are asleep they are all so
unconscious they get taken over by the
collective mental emotional pattern and
the mental story they just inherited
from their parents and then they pass it
on to their children and then they and
each generation suffers they suffer they
come and suffer think right for each
each other
and at some point
the suffering becomes almost unbearable
for certain people within that society
and that's the beginning of
a shift when it gets too much so
suffering drives humans
to appoint
of Awakening it's a strange Paradox here
is
the suffering is created by the
unconsciousness in humans
but in some strange way
eventually it wakes you up it awakens
you
that's the redeeming feature behind the
suffering that humans create for each
other
eventually it leads to a spiritual
awakening
so
it all is a good thing to realize it all
comes down to your state of
consciousness
and how you relate to the people around
you and that spreads that is what
creates the world
and even how you react to when you
listen to the world news
that has a certain influence because all
[Music]
all human minds are connected at a
deeper level
so the way in which you react to what
you hear on the world news contributes
either to the unconsciousness if you get
on the on your computer or the iPad and
you type in
this guy does not deserve to live
[Music]
he should be
die slowly
then you become part of the same Karma
if you've ever done that please forgive
yourself
and if you enjoy reading those comments
also forgive yourself life is always now
this seems almost too obvious to state
but most people live in a way that
almost contradicts the simple fact that
life is always now they live as if some
future moments were more important than
this moment so most people always live
towards the next one and they're always
on their way towards the next moment so
if they get very old then usually they
live in the past and they still don't
live in the present moment so we're not
talking here about making plans and on a
practical level all this is necessary
and great making clients what to do with
your life or what to do the next day but
most people are never at home in the
present moment there's always something
missing there's an inner feeling that I
need to get to the next moment where I
will find some kind of completion of
fulfillment but when they get to the
next moment another next moment appears
that they need to get to
so there's first of all the simple fact
that life is always now
so it's we can learn instead of
continuously
ignoring
the present moment we can first of all
realize the amazing fact that
your entire life
is experienced
in and as the present moment
life is never not the present moment
so it's the most precious thing we have
it's we could say it's the only thing we
have
because the future what we call the
future never actually comes nobody has
ever experienced the future because the
moment the so-called future comes we
experience it as the present moment
again the past when we talk or think
about the past we can only do that in
the present moment
so even thinking about the past and
thinking about future is ultimately
happens in the present moment
now what we when we are always
mentally projecting forward into the
next moment we miss the aliveness and
vitality
of this moment which is ultimately all
there ever is
I think it's an amazing realization that
the many many people
never actually get to a place where they
are able to accept for brief moments
where they're able to uh
come into a
good relationship with the present
moment it's amazing there are millions
of people on the planet who live in an
almost antagonistic relationship with
the present moment they they don't they
don't
ever want to be where they are they'd
rather be somewhere else they may be
engaged in some kind of activity but
they'd rather be doing something else or
they'd rather be already at the end of
this particular activity
they may be with somebody but they don't
really want to be with them they'd
rather be somewhere else you know the
bumper sticker on some cars that says
it's like things like I'd rather be
golfing I'd rather be fishing
so there's this um
strange fact that
the present moment is treated by in by
people internally either as antagonistic
but I just need to get to some better
moment or as a means to an end it's
always a means to an end
so when you are engaged in an activity
you're already mentally projecting
yourself to the next moment where the
activity comes to an end or whatever you
want to achieve through the activity
so
it's like being on a journey and or
mentally projecting yourself to the
destination and not realizing that the
journey
takes let's say you're on a journey
it takes a week arriving at the
destination is a one brief moment and
there you are it takes one week to get
there but if you reduce
the value of the steps that you are
taking in this moment if you reduce that
to always only a means to an end then
your entire life becomes a means to an
end
an end that never really arrives because
when you arrive at that moment then
something else immediately pops up that
you need to reach you won't really enjoy
the fruit of your labors
if perpetually you cannot be present in
the moment
no matter what you'd see if the
enjoyment will be short-lived because of
the habitual pattern
of dissatisfaction in the background
it's always there some obscure sense of
lack and often it comes into the
foreground There's real unhappiness
frustration
and then if you realize that there's
always this waiting for the next thing
which is a thought when you're waiting
for the next thing you're trapped in
thought because that's where future
happens
now
the realization that this is happening
to you is very important the first step
is the beginning of something else
arising
and in all of you that has already
Arisen or that occasionally it still
gets obscured perhaps probably I assume
something else hasn't risen that's not
thought that is beyond thought the
ability to recognize thought
the ability to recognize certain
patterns that habitually arise in your
mind your mental emotional field
the ability to witness that which arises
in your mental emotional field
that's an enormous
belief in consciousness
another dimension one could say has
arisen
we could call it presence we could call
it awareness
it's not thought
but it's intelligence
so intelligence is not confined to
thought
there is a dimension in you
that is far
greater far more intelligence than any
intelligent thought
it's the place from where all
intelligence arises a place of where all
creativity arises
[Music]
so there's the ability to suddenly be
aware of your inner states to be aware
of what your mind is saying the The
Narrative the habitual narrative that
you're telling yourself you're having a
monologue or many people have a dialogue
with themselves where they split
themselves in two and then this one
argues with the other why aren't you
good enough why did you do this why do
you never get anything right we
shouldn't have he shouldn't have said
that yes but on the other so you can
have a dialogue in your narrative or you
can have a monologue it says I am such a
miserable creature because a lot of the
time the narratives the unconscious
thought processes tend to be more
negative than positive for many many
people
foreign
so to be aware that this is happening
that's an enormous gain in Consciousness
it's the beginning of Awakening oh
spiritually speaking
something arises that is not part of the
conditioned mind patterns
so there's the ability to observe your
inner states and that's a wonderful
little pointer to ask yourself
uh frequently
wants my inner State at this moment
and then look at it direct your
attention to it the narratives what have
I been telling myself
and the emotion that accompanies the
narrative
what am I feeling what's the emotion
so in addition to it being a story in
your head
and an emotion
there's a knowing behind it
there's a space behind it
sometimes I call it Inner Space better
than Inner Space
from where you can be aware of what's
Happening
on the level of the person the
personality
because that Inner Space the awareness
is not part of the personality it's but
it's the being
the knowing that is inherent in the
being I haven't gone through physical
death yet
uh as the
zen master who was asked
about
life after death
said I don't know
and they said why don't you know you're
the master
and he said yeah but I'm not a dead
master
[Music]
but I've gone very deeply to what one
could call death to identification with
form
so in a way I have gone into that Realm
from where I can say and know that
ultimately what we see as death
is the dissolution of form that the
Eternal in US which I know that
firsthand cannot be touched by that so
what exactly happens
I would say depends on
whatever state of consciousness
you were in that was be a predominant
State of Consciousness in this lifetime
if in this lifetime
you were continuously identified with
form
your body
or the psychological form of me
that means consciousness
this expression of consciousness
was still in a somewhat dreamlike state
which is identification with form
and
you can easily extrapolate from that if
the tendency of Consciousness to
identify with form was still there which
in other words
The Awakening had not happened
this tendency will continue there will
be further identification with form and
the process will continue as the
Consciousness that is not yet fully
awake
will continue to identify with form
again
and then gradually
come to a place where Awakening happens
or if
there has already been a
disidentification from form in this
lifetime
then you can extrapolate from there that
the compulsive urge to identify with
form and to seek another
form or another cycle of form
identification
this compulsion to seek further
experiences through through identifying
with form
then would either be much weaker
or be completely absent
in which case the Consciousness that you
are
is no longer bound
to
this realm and will not seek to
re-experience the realm of form
but in either case
you really
I know I can tell you that all is well
does not really matter whether
this person
now needs further
experiences of identification in which
case this will happen
or whether he is already
free of this urge in which case
he will move on and
live in a realm that we can't even
conceive of
from where we are here I get a sense
deep within in the forms of what that is
but we don't need to talk about it here
all we know is
nothing
this is the beginning of the Course in
Miracles
which is the entire course in Miracle
summarized in two lines
nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal exists
herein lies the peace of God
that which is real in him is beyond form
anybody can know that when you see a
dead body you realize that this is no
longer whom you knew this is not the
this is not the being that you knew this
is only a shell
so nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal ultimately exists
this is why
sages from all Traditions speak of this
realm of form is ultimately illusory It
ultimately depends what level you look
at
the important thing is
all is well
beyond the appearance on the level of
form which is the only level where
deaths exists it's easy transition from
from one form
into another form or from one form into
formlessness
that is what death is no more than that
nothing real dies nothing real dies
which is to say ultimately
there is no such thing as death there
only seems to be it's a transmutation or
form either form dissolves or seek some
other form some other identification
with form first you see the need to be a
victim identity also unfortunately is a
form of ego
because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be employees justified in having a
victim identity because of the things
that other humans did to you you
yourself are finding you are finding
yourself in a kind of prison
that created by your mind
so there's no denial of that bad things
happen to you yes
now question is
how do you exit
this mental present
the first step is perhaps to see
um
that
unconscious human beings
unconscious human beings in the grip of
their own conditioning their own ego
and
they have virtually no free will
when you are unconscious you are
controlled by
the the Mind patterns that are lodged in
your psyche
you have you cannot really speak of Free
Will by somebody who has zero awareness
and yet the entire makeup is
conditioning from the past
so
the famous sentence phrase used by Jesus
the in connection with forgiveness on
the cross he said forgive them for they
know not what they do
now these these two interesting these
points put together
forgive them why forgive them
they know not what they do in other
words if he had spoken these days using
our terminology
he probably would have said they are
completely unconscious
because that's what it means they know
not what they do they are completely
unconscious
so when you see nobody can act beyond
their level of consciousness
then you see that it's almost like it
becomes almost like the evil that was
perpetrated it becomes almost like a
natural phenomenon
that is like you've been hit by
lightning or something or
lived in very unpleasant
climatic conditions that that injured
you
near volcano
and my dad what had problems with anger
huge the outbursts of anger quite
frequently it was living like living the
legs to a volcano they could erupt at
any moment
um and he could not help it it was it
was impossible there was no possibility
of being different
and so these humans are run by
unconscious conditioning usually goes
back to their childhood and what
happened there
I know why my father was angry I I
needed a republic I realized much later
that it all originated in his childhood
the the reasons why he was so angry and
also
for a while also I felt a resentment
towards that and only when I was able to
awaken out of egoic consciousness
I saw that there's nothing that he could
have done differently because there
wasn't enough awareness
now
when you see that then you don't
personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that there's first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their conditioning
in the absence of awareness
if there's awareness they can transcend
their conditioning and then they begin
to become conscious of their own
conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes
so they couldn't
they can't help it so that's that's
already a useful step in forgiveness but
it you may not yet be able to arrive at
at full forgiveness because of that
another before I continue with that
does that mean then a question may arise
in your mind
doesn't mean then humans are not really
responsible for what they do
if they are unconscious how are they
responding does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them from what they do
if they commit a crime
are they not guilty
that's an interesting question
the
the unconsciousness
that operate inhuman even if you are
able to forgive a human when we come we
will go more fully into that in a minute
even if you're able to forgive and human
for their transgressions or whatever
they did
uh this does not mean and even though
the human is not responsible for their
unconsciousness and yet
it is built into the structure of human
life
they still need to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
when I look at you first thing I would
see is your personality and of course
the physical body and the personality
whatever makes up your personality but
if I look more deeply and not just look
but actually sense your presence I know
that beyond your personality there is an
Essence in you that it is one with the
essence in me and one good to describe
it as Consciousness itself the essence
of Who You Are the essence of who I am
is consciousness
when I recognize that Consciousness the
same Consciousness that in me this
Consciousness beyond the condition
itself
recognizes the Consciousness in you that
which is beyond your conditioned self
and that recognition
is what Jesus called love
and therefore he said
love thy neighbor as thyself
but that as a separate statement it
doesn't work but when you put it
together with Kingdom of Heaven that
then it reads
find the Kingdom of Heaven within you
the dimension of spaciousness
then you will recognize your neighbor
which is anybody that you are with
then you will recognize him or her as
yourself and this recognition that in
essence you are one that you are deeply
deeply connected that you share the con
the one Consciousness when you recognize
them in the other then you have suddenly
an outflow of benevolence and Good Will
and love
not the ego love but true love towards
the which in the Old Testament in the
New Testament Agape spiritual love for
another human being you can sense their
very beings
so and that's the whole secret of the of
of all spirituality it's in these in the
teaching of Jesus you need the chance
and you need to challenge yourself if
you want to create something if you want
to bring about some change in this world
you want to make your life your
so-called life better you are looking to
achieve this or to learn this or to
acquire this that's part of being human
we don't deny that
and if you don't want to achieve
anything let's say you have no ambition
whatsoever and say oh it's all pointless
because you don't want to be you don't
want to challenge yourself
then life will challenge you even more
if you don't if you're challenging
yourself would be even to engage in
physical activity and jogging you're
challenging yourself or you're lifting
weights for your challenging the body on
a physical level the only way you can
make the body stronger the physical body
is by making let's put I'll put it like
this it's a strange way of putting it
but it's true
you have to make life difficult for your
body
otherwise it doesn't get stronger
well to lift the way it is I mean if you
ask the body would you rather have a
good just relax or lift his weight
no I just want to relax
I don't want to make my John make my
life more difficult than it needs to be
so I just okay you don't get stronger
without the but when you you make life
difficult for the body then more energy
is demanded and more energy comes
flowing in
the energy isn't come until you demand
it there's a request or demand for
energy because there's a there's a gap
between uh what you want and what at the
moment the body doesn't have enough
energy and suddenly it comes then you
reach a point when an influx of energy
starts then you it's no longer perceived
that the the
you make life difficult for your body
once the Energy starts flowing the body
enjoys this law of energy but before the
Energy starts flowing life was difficult
for the body
and so you always you meet always the
the threshold of life gets difficult for
the body and then energy comes in and
then suddenly not even perceived as
difficult anymore and that you may
experience it every day when you start
exercising certain actions take place
you do things you know
they're not
the optimal things to do but you can't
help it it's something
acts through you
um there's there seems to be some power
there that makes you do things
that you know no I'm not right or not
good for you and yet you can't stop it
that seems to be the case
um
and that of course
is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but
um
this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking
there's something that overpowers them
in you that seems to obscure
the awareness
or the awareness is pushed to to recite
and this thing this this powerful thing
does it anyway
thank you
and again my answer is a little bit
similar to
um
what I say to the first question uh
tonight
the
the power of presence
needs to grow in you so that
it is strong enough not to it's not
willpower because willpower is not
the best way of dealing with these
things but
it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the application of a
force to hold something down let's say
um
if you're addiction is to
have a to indulge in
intoxicating beverages in other words
booze is the British word uh
then
and you can feel it it comes on there it
comes you know the bottles are there
there they are and you feel you have to
go then you have to reach out and you
have to pour yourself a drink now
when you're not aware at all you don't
even know what you're doing you're so
unconscious that you you're already
holding the drink and you're drinking
then you
at that point you you even know that
you're drinking uh the same with food
I've spoken to people who've had
addictions to food they often say they
wake up when they're around they've
already eaten in the middle of the night
they've already unconsciously gone to
the fridge taking out the chocolate cake
and then they're already halfway through
the chocolate cake when somebody's like
what am I doing
but so awareness comes in at a very late
point
willpower would be to hold an urge down
let's say our God they have the poor or
even what's the example yoga if you want
to turn on the TV and you know it it's
not right because I I'm not here for
that and he actually told us not to do
it
help it I have to go I can't I can't no
willpower you would you would say I'm
going to hold this on I'm not going to
do it
and I can confirm the odds but you're
holding it down
um when you hold things down
often after a while
an explosion happens it's like a boiling
kettle
can't hold it for that long and then you
have some kind of rationalization in
your mind but it's you'll do it anyway
the mind will give you a reason the
ability to think of course was a
wonderful evolutionary achievement
it is associated also it's linked to the
development of language too so gradually
humans develop the ability to think and
it was a wonderful evolutionary
evolutionary advance
but over the over many many Millennia
the the thinking activity began to take
over and so most human beings these days
actually never stop thinking so what
they experience is what I call a voice
in the head
which is the internal dialogue that most
people
experience experience throughout the day
during their waking hours
there's this continuous inner dialogue
taking place monologue dialogue whatever
you want to call it there's a there's a
commentator in the in your mind that
interprets immediately and judges
situations and people and and things
it spends much more time thinking about
some other moment rather than this one
and usually it's the future
and and some people of course dwell
excessively on the past too they carry
around the burden of past in their minds
and in and in their emotional field
without knowing it without realizing
that it doesn't have to be that way
without realizing that they are allowing
the past which after all is only certain
thoughts that they carry in the head
they're allowing the past to uh to
sabotage their whole life they're
carrying such a burn of past that they
can no longer experience the present so
you're either burdened by the past or
you're burdened by the future now the
question of why is very important what
what is the ultimate cause of this and
that is the what one could call
overthinking
thinking was a wonderful thing and still
is a wonderful thing but it has taken
over human beings it has
proliferated to such an extent that now
thinking has become almost a
a
parasitical entity that lives in your in
your head that won't leave you alone
you now
but most people's sense of identity most
people sense of who they are is
bound up with their mind activity with
their thinking so they derive their
sense of self from certain stories that
they're telling themselves
in their mind and that's to do with what
happened in the past what other people
did to you things you identify with that
these are
thoughts things that belong to me these
are my things these are all thought
formations
so people identify with the voice in the
head
and the voice in the head
becomes
a
yeah for them impossible to to
distinguish from who they are
so they talk to themselves in that you
everybody has met people in the street
who
talk themselves out aloud and usually
people look at them say oh there's a
crazy person going
but virtually everybody does it except
that they don't do it out aloud if you
could listen into when if you look walk
around in this city if you could listen
to but what's going on in people's heads
you would realize they're all talking to
themselves a lot of chatter yes and they
are so identified with it that they they
kind of they are it the voice has taken
you over the the the the Mind activity
the conceptual mind has taken you over
and then it becomes virtually becomes
you so in that state which in spiritual
terms we call unconscious when we use
the word unconscious in in spiritual
terms right certainly does not have the
same meaning as as it has in
conventional terms usually when we use
unconscious and conventional jobs we're
talking about somebody who is just
dropped off but he's unconscious when we
use the word unconscious in spiritual
terms it means it refers to somebody who
is totally identified with the stream
the consent continuous stream of
thinking which is conditioned by the
past the types of thoughts that you
think the stories that you continuously
revive in your head
are have been conditioned by your past
and the past of the culture that you
grew up in the country you grew up in
all the things that make up your past
your personal past and the collective
past of your
environment so a person who grew up in
let's say Saudi Arabia will not be
thinking the same kind of stories and
will not interpret the world in the same
way as somebody who grew up in Canada or
in the west but what they have in common
they are both identified with the
continuous stream of think they may be
different stories there may be a
different sense of identity but but in
both cases they are they they cannot
they cannot separate themselves from The
Voice in the head is religion necessary
it is depends who you are on the level
of the farm for some people it can be
necessary or helpful
for two reasons
it can provide the more superficial
reason
it can give your life a certain amount
of structure which for some people can
be helpful
regular practice
gives you a feeling of comfort
some people have too little structure in
their lives and others have too much
already
if you have too little structure in your
life then religion can provide
that
more importantly on another level
religion can either obscure
the
spiritual Dimension within yourself
and often it does
or
if used rightly if approached rightly if
understood
on a deeper level
it can
help you
access and stay in connectedness
with that deeper level of yourself or
the Transcendent dimension of
consciousness
whether or not you need it only you can
know whether you find it either helpful
or a hindrance
we can be either depend depends on
you as a person your past what function
it had in your past
and so on
it is a hindrance
if religion becomes an ideology
then it operates only on the level of
the Mind
and it's very similar to any other kind
of ideology that you may believe in
whether it's
communism as a as an ideology or any
foreign
political Theory or anything that
explains the universe it could be a
metaphysical system that you completely
believe in
philosophical system and so on
so an ideology is something that takes
possession of your mind
and exerts a controlling function
and it can influence
almost the entire mental functioning if
it becomes something of
overwhelming power in your mind it's a
it's a little thought that grows into a
huge thing in your mind and the
tentacles breeds into every aspect of
your mind and there are religious people
like that
usually you can recognize that it is an
ideology
by the fact that they are not peaceful
human beings
and by the fact that
they have
enemies
either even within their own religion
or another religion anybody who does not
agree with their ideology
becomes an enemy in the same way the
people who were not nowadays that many
were deeply believing in communism which
was a wonderful idea to start with of
course
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions it was a beautiful idea of
equality
everybody the same that is wonderful no
personal possessions sounds wonderful
too
and the only mistake was
it was imposed from outside by people
who themselves has not gone beyond the
egoic State of Consciousness they just
played it in their mind isn't that's a
good idea
and then it was imposed on on other
people who also were not in that state
of consciousness but most importantly
those who impose the idea on others
forced them to live it out
the idea became contaminated with ego
so when these people came to power
their egos
became inflated to an enormous degree
almost to absurdity and without
realizing it
they
uh
re-enacted
the same
evils and in some cases worse than those
that they were fighting against
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
I'll see you there I believe that your
personality creates your personal
reality and in order to change your
personal reality your life it means then
that on some level we have to change
because nothing changes in our life
unless we change